gurú de las finanzas magnate de bienes
raíces estrella de reality shows y
presidente número 45 de eeuu
nació en 1946 en nueva york' la ciudad
donde donald trump empezó a dejar huella
una vez graduado de la escuela de
finanzas cuarto and siguió los pasos de
su padre en el mundo del desarrollo
inmobiliario heredando una fortuna puso
su nombre en rascacielos hoteles casinos
y campos de golf pero también enfrentó
numerosas bancarrotas el reality show
the apprentice en 2004 le devolvió
riqueza y llevó su imagen directamente a
millones de hogares estadounidenses
una plataforma para saltar hacia su
siguiente objetivo a la presidencia el
30 de abril de 2011 trump asistió a la
cena anual de corresponsales de la casa
blanca convirtiéndose en blanco de las
burlas de barack obama una humillación
que según asesores políticos le dio un
impulso imparable así entró en la
carrera presidencial de 2015 como
precandidato republicano
generando polémica desde el primer día
están trayendo drogas están trayendo
crimen son violadores y algunos asumo
son buenas personas son más del tipo su
imagen de outsider y de hombre de
negocios calo con buena parte de una
sociedad decepcionada con el
establecimiento político y en noviembre
de 2016 dejó en shock al mundo
derrotando a hillary clinton llegó con
promesas de corte nacionalista como la
construcción de un muro en la frontera y
el retiro del país de acuerdos
comerciales según el dañinos
eeuu primero eeuu primero 34 años de
escándalos ataques a la prensa y tweets
ser precious su presidencia estuvo
marcada por una guerra comercial con
china acercamientos a corea del norte
máximas tensiones con irán el traslado
de la embajada estadounidense a
jerusalén y el logro del
restablecimiento de relaciones
diplomáticas de varios países con israel
confirmó también a más de 250 jueces
federales incluyendo tres jueces de la
corte suprema
y enfrentó investigaciones por la
presunta corrupción de su campaña con
rusia
justo como la de rusia rusia rusia fue
una farsa
no hubo colusión colisión se convirtió
además en el tercer presidente en la
historia del país en enfrentar un juicio
político
artículo 1 adoptado
se autoproclamó presidente de tiempos de
guerra al enfrentar la pandemia de kobe
19 y padeció él mismo una enfermedad que
mató a más de 220.000 personas en el
país enfrentando una crisis sanitaria
pero también económica a donald chan
promete una rápida recuperación si el
pueblo le da las llaves de la casa
blanca por segunda vez
[Música]